à côté au coin d'accord c'est
cool oh tu es juste à côté du terrain de
golf un gros séquoias celui-ci juste
ici avec le grand pont de séquoias au
coin ok je vois juste là tu sais Hé
regarde nous ouvrons un bateau nous  faire pour
mendier ok arrêter le tableau k allons boire des
bières et arrêter d'enregistrer inscrivez-vous à tout
moment pour faire ça ok
Buffalo juste là oh ouais on a ton
bip bonjour regarde il y a une bonne photo
juste là ouais c'est la fosse à balles de
Plenty boulangerie numérique open vida  hein
Teddy j'ai suivi par Midler arrête de
courir au milieu c'est une blague nous allons juste un
truc solitaire comme ça
personne ne se rapproche trop vous serez
tous les deux
là ouais c'est un réservoir de chat pour le
tenir d'accord Le soleil est parti comme toi  sais que
vous financez les gars, hein, celui-ci est obtenu, alors
qu'est-ce que les briseurs de voitures ont encore,
Sam a mis une pancarte à droite, nous nous
sentons
parce que tout ce que j'ai envie de dire, c'est tout